what is a high concept
idea I'll try to answer it but I
actually think it's a total mistake to
think that way so um what I was taught
and I think what most people are taught
is a high concept is bigger bigger is
better and a high concept is is a
concept That's so exciting that people
are going to want to buy this not they
don't even need to see the characters or
the script just that concept is great
and you know a classic example people
will give is Jaws you know which was
huge Blockbuster movie or people talk
about breaking bad um look there's a lot
of different people out there everyone
has their opinion and different people
resonate with you um I I personally will
ignore anyone who says that and I will
suspect they've never had a career as a
writer I've sold a lot of pitches I've
helped writers sell pitches first off uh
here's the concept of Jaws and just
pretend Jaws didn't exist and I came in
and you're an executive and here I pitch
at you all right so there's a shark and
it's like killing people and these three
guys get on a boat and they got to go
kill the shark are you like oh my God
that's the best idea ever I that is just
a no I mean Jaws was hugely successful
so they use it as an example but like
that concept it's an interesting concept
but like or Breaking Bad you know that's
such a great concept people would buy it
in the room well that's really I think
interesting information of Vin Gilligan
because he pitched that everywhere in
town for four years and everyone passed
so if that's such a high concept that
everyone would buy it that's really
interesting so here's the thing bigger
is not better this is writers torture
themselves oh it's this love story but
I've got a meteor coming to crash like
whoa whoa whoa whoa you don't want to go
bigger you want to go
deeper so you want to go deeper and and
you really want to figure out what is
most interesting about your concept and
how do you make it more interesting and
how do you make it more
interesting and I'll give you an example
just just just cuz it's top of head not
that um so there's a show that some of
you may know some of you may not know on
Apple TV and it's called slow horses and
it is a uh
British uh like uh Thriller and so
you've probably heard of MI5 which is
like the CIA like think about MI5 in
London it's like very Sleek
sophisticated computers people are
well-dressed and it is like the top
spies okay well in London they have
other um part they have other
departments and one of them is called
slow or slow horse which they call slow
horse and slow horse is the place you're
sent if you really messed up and they
want to punish you um it is like the
reject loser spy place to go to and so
if you want to be a spy you want to be
an MI5 maybe you were an MI5 and if you
did something terribly wrong you get
reassigned to SL horse or slow horse and
you wouldn't want anyone to know that
because you'd be the laughing stock of
the Spy community and once you go to
slow horses there's only one thing you
want to do which is find your way out
and back to MI5 only there you don't
it's hell you don't leave hell if you
get if you get sent to slow horses it's
terrible and uh Gary Oldman is the lead
and he plays a guy who was uh a James
Bond type you know super spy and he now
runs
slow horses which is a really
interesting question like why did he get
this worst job ever and I'm not going to
answer that for those of you want to go
watch the show you do eventually find
the reason so this is now you think
about this this could be uh the
beginnings of a concept for comedy it
could be a straight Thriller drama you
could actually go a lot of ways with
this so this is a um it's a thriller
with you know a little bit of humor but
it's not it's not played for Laughs this
is not the bad news bearers of spies
okay
so now if you're developing this this is
an interesting idea I think you walk in
like you've heard of MI5 you've heard of
the CIA did you know that there's slow
horses you talk about that and then you
talk about these characters and what
they did to get there and of course some
of them deserved it and others of them
just insulted the wrong person's wife
accidentally and now out of spite and so
they have their stories and they want to
get out of there but they can't and what
do they do is they get assigned like the
parking management jobs right like so if
there's a potential terrorist uh MI5 is
going to Trail the person and do all
this stuff and slow horses is literally
doing traffic control I mean they do the
most menial horrible things okay not
horrible but just meaning boring stuff
well now you're like okay this it's a
great idea but as a concept what are we
watching we we in and week out we're
going to watch these people do traffic
control I think that's going to get
pretty boring so you start
thinking what could be a case that they
have to do that's going to be really
interesting of course you also got to
figure out why would they get that case
that's part of a writer you got to
figure that out and so You' think well
let's let's find them having to go up
against a really strong adversary the
the KGB or the Chinese intelligence or
the CIA or mad and you'd be like yeah
here are these people and by the way
this is part of the fun of the show when
we see MI5 it's like everyone's
beautiful suits and clothing super
high-tech computers uh they all drive or
are chauffeured in these bulletproof
black SUVs slow horses is this like
decrepid little building with no air
conditioning there's one computer I mean
they they also Drive their own cars and
it's these little I mean it's just like
this pathetic little operation now if
they have to go against the
KGB wow like the there no way they're
going to be able to do that and if
there's real stakes and that could be a
really cool concept but you got to go
deeper you got to say what would be even
more interesting would the CIA be more
interesting in the KGB or mad or
or MI5
what if they're what if the adversar is
MI5 these people who are MI5 got kicked
out and they got nothing what if they
got to go against MI5 what if MI5 is
doing something very illegal and
dangerous and slow horses figures it out
and now they got to go undercover and
out spy outsmart these people that's a
concept that you could sell so is that
bigger no it's more interesting that's
how you heighten and go deeper you take
what is interesting and you keep asking
methodical questions to make it as
interesting as possible and that very
much can be the difference between
people are interested in you and people
buying your work and hiring you I was
taught how to do this by a producer I
never would have sold Metropolis to
rudley Scott had I not known how to
heighten that was Metropolis High
concept it was heightened concept I
don't believe in high concept High
concept is bigger is better now bigger
isn't better what we want is impactful
we want to make something interesting
and make it as interesting as possible
and instead of going bigger and high by
the way something that always frustrates
me you talk to anyone who believes in
high concept and you say Define it they
can't or they'll give you a definition
that makes no sense uh they'll say well
it's a concept that when people it they
want to buy it oh well that's really
helpful after the fact you know that's a
toy that's not going to help anybody um
so I don't believe in high concept I
think that's a trap I believe in
heightened
Concepts